[Musique]
moi j'ai une capacité d'arrosage
d'environ deux mois non-stop c'est à
dire que je puise dans des forages et au
bout d'un moment le débit se réduit donc
si j'arrose correctement les blés je
crains derrière ne pas avoir assez d'eau
pour arroser correctement les maïs
jusqu'à fin août pour avoir une bonne
ray
[Musique]
on
généralisé de stockage de l'eau partout
où c'est possible partout où c'est
possible parce que sinon il va se passer
un phénomène c'est qu'il ya sata série
tout territoire qui vont carrément être
abandonné tout simplement parce qu'en
fait quand il ya plus de rentabilité
économique il ya plus de raisons d'être
sur le territoire
[Musique]
il